I just moved here so you first moved
here a while back but what was it like
when you 1976 I moved here uh did you
love it I loved it yeah I grew up in
Philly and um not far yeah it's not far
it's not far I've been here a few times
because my sister lived here my sister
lived on um on West End Avenue so she
was very nice to let me sleep on her
couch for probably I don't know four
months until I got my feet that's nice
on the ground yeah yeah cuz it's not a
cheap City no no although I can tell you
that in
1976 uh my budget for my apartment was
$150 a month so you lived in a closet
right well of someone else's of someone
else's closet right well that what what
happened was was I I figured that it was
100 I don't know where I got the math on
that but that's what that's how I that's
what I had decided yeah and um so I went
into this I saw an ad in the back of the
Village Voice and it said uh artists
actors musicians res residence and I
thought well that's that sounds good it
was basically a flop house really I
mean I don't I guess there were some
some artists there but not a lot like do
you mind living with rats exactly yeah
exactly but I walked into the into the
rental office and the guy said no we
don't have any single room Apartments uh
but we do have a two room apartment so
basically it was a kitchen and another
room and uh I said he said that's three
and a quarter a month and I said I can't
afford that and I don't have a roommate
and he said what about this guy I'm
sitting on the couch and I I looked of
this guy and he goes you want to live
together and I was like yeah okay yeah
okay we'll live together yeah and we
lived together for four years oh my gosh
yeah in fact I just had uh lunch with
him the other day and um uh he was a he
was a classical
pianist uh were you both musicians yeah
that's cool yeah he he was he's great
great um played beautiful I mean i' be
you know in the middle of the afternoon
he worked nights at the Copa gabana and
in the middle of the after this is a TV
show this is what he what yeah yeah I I
i' he'd come home and he'd be playing
you know chopan or whatever and it was
it was it was really cool that's incred
I actually moved out to LA with some
random person I did not know really yeah
she just needed a roommate I was like
I'll do it I was like and I moved from
Texas to LA with a stranger wow how long
did that last not long we moved into and
it burned down um so yeah then I slipped
in my car for a few days and then tried
out for a show called American Idol so
it all worked
out it all work
out life yeah I feel like everyone in
this industry has some crazy thing where
you've either lived in your car or on a
mattress in someone's house or yeah it's
like yeah you really got to want your
dream you do you got to have the hung
the universe makes you really
[Music]
wanted
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home